[music playing]
NARRATOR: Fuxian Lake,
Yunnan province, China, 1992.
Expert diver Geng Wei
descends into this remote lake
and discovers a
surprising phenomenon--
the bottom is littered
with hand-carved flagstones
and other stone relics.
The mysterious stones lie
scattered on the bottom
of China's
second-deepest freshwater
lake, which covers an
area of 100 square miles
with a depth of 509 feet.
What he saw was
quite extraordinary--
hand-dressed flagstones, roads,
buildings, and it's as if he
discovered an underwater city.
The clearest evidence of
dwellings at the bottom
of a lake.
It was built when
there wasn't a lake.
And that would mean that
we're talking about a time
before the last ice age, which
would bring the story of Fuxian
Lake way more into
the remote past
than what we're being told.
DAVID CHILDRESS: Geng Wei made
over 35 days in Fuxian Lake,
and they even took a
submarine down into this lake
to find stairs, and more
of these flagstones,
and walls beneath this lake.
So you have to wonder--
did some kind of advanced
civilization exist at one time
beneath Fuxian Lake?
NARRATOR: In 2001,
archaeologists from the Yunnan
Provincial Museum used
advanced sonar scanners
and cameras to conduct
the monumental task
of surveying Fuxian Lake.
The evidence collected
convinced Chinese archaeologists
they had discovered structures
of an advanced civilization,
including an arena-type
building and pyramids.
This mysterious
sunken city covers
more than one square mile,
but the questions remain--
who built it?
And why?
The pyramid itself is
very unusual, and it is
said that the pyramid is as old
as the Egyptian pyramids are,
and maybe even higher
than some of them.
It's an incredible discovery.
DAVID CHILDRESS:
Ancient Chinese records
speak of a city in the area
of Fuxian Lake called Yuyuan.
However, studies of the
underwater structures
at Fuxian Lake show
that it's actually much
older than this Yuyuan city.
Could this be the
remains of some
ancient and advanced
society that was
destroyed in the Great Flood?
NARRATOR: Is it possible
that an extraterrestrial base
is located deep underwater?
Ancient astronaut
theorists say yes,
and suggest USOs, or
unidentified submersible
objects, have been
well-chronicled
in ancient Chinese texts.
NICK REDFERN: According
to "Cheng Jang Fu "Zhi,
a book written during
the reign of Emperor
Daoguang in the Qing
dynasty, a horse-like monster
lived in the lake.
The animal was described as
being white with red spots
on its back.
More intriguingly, it
was a creature that could
actually take to the skies.
This suggests it may have
been part-USO, part-UFO.
That's to say, an underwater
submersible object and also
an unidentified flying object.
NARRATOR: October 24, 1991.
A local fisherman named Zhang
Yuxiang was fishing on fishing
on Fuxian Lake during a
clear and tranquil day,
when a dense fog suddenly rolled
across the vast body of water.
In 1991, Zhang Yuxiang, a
fisherman, was at Fuxian Lake
when he encountered a UFO.
Now, this strange
craft actually emerged
from the waters of the lake.
He described it
as a shining disk.
This UFO was so
close and so powerful
that it actually
tossed the boat around.
And then rapidly,
this craft just
disappeared up into the sky.
Lake Fuxian is
clearly an area where
there have been many strange
events over the years.